all right so uh
welcome back i'm sorry
okay so uh all right so the last hour
during the first talk we saw what
lattices are what lattice problems are
we saw an average case hard problem the
short integer solutions and we showed
how to
construct collision resistant dash
functions from it we showed a worst case
traverse case reductions
well then now let's move on all right
but before i do that
i want to clarify something that came up
in this worst case traverse case
reduction
which is a question by tal and another
one that david david
somewhere asked right which is that uh
you know why do i
pick a random lattice point and add
gaussian noise to it why don't i pick so
if a fixed lattice point let's say zero
and add a gaussian really the key reason
i do this believe it or not is to ensure
that uh the lattice vector that i
construct the short lattice vector i
construct
is not a zero vector right it sounds
it sounds trivial since this should be
the easiest thing to prove right but it
isn't this is really the core of the
analysis and the difficulty
comes in because of the following let's
say for a moment
that uh the adversary right i mean
obviously looks at these a is this this
sis instance and the ai sort of tells it
what these y
i's are right so because i looked at the
y i's i looked at the coefficients
that's how i constructed this sis
instance so he kind of knows what these
y eyes are
and now he thinks i mean this guy is a
computationally all-powerful guy right
because i'm doing a reduction black box
reduction
so he thinks about it and says well let
me pick
an sis solution r1 up to rm
so that the sum of r i e i
is zero right
if he can look at y i and figure out
exactly what this e
i is he can do it he has all the power
in the world he can
he can potentially do it and then i'm
screwed i ask him once he says
ask him once again he says zero third
time is a zero okay so i somehow want to
argue that this cannot happen
why can't this not happen the point is
the key
point here is an information theoretic
argument it says that given y i
this noisy lattice point there are many
possible choices of ease of eyes
and what does that mean it could it
either comes in because i chose a random
lattice point so
i could have chose this lattice point
and added this error
or i could have chosen this lattice
point and added this error right i mean
the adversary looks at y and he doesn't
know what the ei is so he cannot screw
me over
right he can sort of make one of the
choices
evaluate to a zero lattice point but not
uh not all
right there's only one point that he can
kill so you somehow have to
run this sort of hiding argument right
namely given y i
there are many possible choices of ei
this is one way to do it because
i chose many different lattice points
another way to do it is to say
you know i'm always going to choose 0 as
my lattice point sample a gaussian
around it
but i don't stop there i reduce it
modulo the parallel pipette i
you know this is exactly like reducing
numbers mod other numbers
right that again ensures that if i give
you the reduced number
you don't know where i started from
there are many possible places you could
have started from and that hides
information again so all this is to
ensure
that the lattice point i reconstruct at
the end is not zero
sounds like a triviality but this is
really absolutely the core of
the analysis here it's actually the core
of many things i mean it's it's really
what happens in the am co-am protocol
for the complement of svp that i showed
you before the goldrich goldwater
protocol
that's what happens you take the aitai
kumar sivakumar
analysis of the two to the n sp time svp
algorithm
that's what happens you all the time you
have to argue that the vector you're
constructing is not zero and
the argument is something similar to
this not sure how much this makes sense
to you but
the point is you somehow have to hide
information from the adversary and has
to be information theoretic
because i'm doing a reduction i don't
know what the guy does he could be
the god right i mean i don't know he
could solve everything
yes okay good
all right so let's move on we're done
with sis
i want to tell you about another average
case
problem which is learning with errors or
lwe
and that is the following problem right
so here it is
i have the only thing i did here is i
moved
the indeterminate the vector here from
left to right or right to left
that's all i did okay so now things
change drastically right so now
instead of being under determined this
is an over determined system of
equations
right another question is can you find s
well you can i mean right gaussian
elimination if there is an s
you'll find it if there is no s you'll
detect it so on and so forth everything
is easy here
again as i did before let me change the
question a little bit
all right so let's say that i give you s
times this
matrix and by the way this matrix is
always public right like in sis
this sort of linear equation which
linear equations i'm working with is
public
i give you an indeterminate s which is
in my head
times this matrix plus a small
error vector in other words like each
sort of coefficient
of s times a this matrix i perturb it by
a little bit
say add you know a random number from
minus eight to eight
something like that right so this is a
parameter of the problem
and i get uh and i get this now my
question is can you find us
out of this first of all it's not even
clear
that uh the choice of s is unique right
because
you know if you choose your parameters
in a funky way
there could be many possible sort of
solutions
to the system but if you choose it in
the right way namely you don't add too
much
error here you get uniqueness
right you if you if i give you many
noisy linear equations it's not too much
noise
the solution is information
theoretically determined it's unique
and the question is can you find it in
polymer time
right that's lwe this again is
hard believed to be hard
very hard i don't know what that is okay
so
so uh more formally i have a which is
the same type of matrix as before it's n
by m
so you know short
thick fat matrix i do s
transpose a plus an error and your goal
is to find s
right that's that's learning with errors
so then i can ask you a philosophical
question i mean
it's great yeah good yeah so it's like i
remember
you know showing my age like in the old
day of lettuce is kind of i was a little
bit
you know because it was not mod q it's
like it's like this thing over reels
there's like no bounding
so it was kind of unfriendly thing and
then and suddenly the only thing where
what you appeared and now all
crypto guys can use a black box
everything is friendly so
what is this philosophy i mean i know
there is a worst case average case yeah
where this mod queue
randomly appears but to me it made
lettuce is kind of much friendless so
i'm just curious what's your perspective
of
mod q kind of coming why did it time so
so first of all it makes it easier to uh
argue about a random object right uh you
know uh so
so so the so the difference in
perspectives was rather than choosing
a random lattice point and sort of work
with this what does it mean choose a
random lattice point
the way that uh mickey and
dwork handle this is to say well let's
kind of pick a really large
kind of rectangle and choose a random
point within this rectangle
right so then you have to deal with all
sorts of boundary issues
it becomes challenging to analyze it
right so rather than say that
uh the new sort of thing in uh the work
of my chance on regime is to say
i'm just going to pick uh instead of
choosing a random lattice point and
adding a gaussian for instance you know
in the worst case rapid squares
reduction
you pick a point from you add the
gaussian to the zero
lattice point since this is you don't
care about
random lattice point it doesn't buy you
anything and reduce it modulo the
parallel pipette so instead of working
with the lattice which is an infinite
group
you work with r to the n modulo the
lattice
which i mean it's not i mean you know
it's something that you can discretize
and you can uh
you can argue about nicely i guess right
so one thing could be that
we just added some more uh
basis vectors which is just multiples of
q okay they're like you know okay i see
so so you're asking
becomes much simpler now because you can
do everything but essentially it still
reveals a lattice problem all you've
done is added multiple
words so this question so this question
of
how is this how is sis a lattice problem
and how is lwa larry's problem what do
they have to do with each other
we'll get back to it trust me in a in a
short while right
but you know the best answer i can think
of maybe other people have
have better answers is that instead of
dealing with sort of
the infinite lattice and kind of saw
dealing with boundary issues you don't
have to do that anymore
you still have to deal with these sort
of uh sort of the epsilon nets right uh
but
it's nicer than uh than the boundary
issues but but that brings up actually a
very interesting point so
so what's happening in lwe's is sort of
uniqueness right so as i said this uh
before
if i give you many sufficiently many
equations the solution even with noise
the solution s is unique and that
philosophically is what lets you do
something like publicly encryption
out of lwe right you need uniqueness if
i give you the encryption of
a message it better be that the message
is uniquely determined
injective trapdoor functions you know if
i give you the output it better be that
the input is uniquely determined and
that's the kind of thing that lwe lets
you
do this was done before actually so
the first sort of public encryption from
lattices was the iotide
work cryptosystem which was based on
the worst case hardness of something
called the unique shortest vector
problem right so which is saying i have
a lattice
i know that the second shortest vector
is
much larger than the first shadow
structure so there's a gap between the
two
can you find so the promise can you find
the shortest director
and you you know that this is very
philosophically very similar to the lwe
problem in that both give you
uniqueness and in fact you can show that
uh you know lwe
can be related to the boundary distance
decoding problem in the worst case and
boundary distance decoding problem and
unique short spectre
are really the same right this is a work
of vadim and uh
maybe daniele so so so uniqueness is the
core
thing here that you get here but you
don't get in sis right
sis seems like the parameter settings
for which the problem was hard
was the collision resistant parameter
settings where you have many solutions
right and not surprisingly this will
give us public interruption
okay so so uh so this is the problem
uh an m will be large enough to make
this
solution unique
okay so it seems very hard let's not
dwell on it
i also want to define a variant of the
lwe problem which is the decisional wwe
problem right it says that uh
given so lwe says given many noisy
equations on a secret s
you cannot find us decisional
interviewee says that if i give you many
noise equations
you can't even tell those from just
random junk
that i threw at you right it's a very
seems like a very uh strong statement to
make a strong assumption
uh to make but the
the interesting thing is that it is not
a strong it's not a strong assumption to
make
these two things are as hard as each
other
this is a very uh a little bit of an
informal statement it depends on the
parameter settings and so on and so
forth but morally
you know if you can solve decisional lwe
you can solve
search view if you can distinguish
between these two guys
you can find the secret
right so very very nice statement not
obvious at all
but uh that's that's what it is
i mean what kind of no no i don't no i
don't
was before right so so this this
statement holds for every error
distribution that you can
maybe i need the error distribution to
be small enough that uh
i have uniqueness but that's about it i
mean it's very sort of agnostic to the
other distribution
the the the catch here which i didn't
tell you and i'm not going to tell you
very much
is that uh in the reduction
right you lose some parameters and what
is that what are those parameters is the
m there's a number of equations in other
words
if you can solve decisional lwe
for something like m equals a hundred
and let's say you get hundred times more
equations and variables
then i can solve search with a lot more
equations
so i'm solving an easier search problem
quantitatively
than the decision so that's a little bit
of a catch but you know i'm really going
to set m to be polynomial in n so i
don't care that's
as a beautiful beautiful theorem and we
are going to
actually uh rely on it black box way
okay so so that's that's lwe really i
mean this should
i mean if you do coding theory this
should remind you of
something like decoding random linear
codes although we're not working with
the hamming norm it's not a little bit
non-standard
that we are actually adding error that
is small in the uh
l2 norm
learning noisy linear functions so on
and so forth and uh it's also related to
uh
latest problems one way one way that
happens is through a
worst case average case reduction the
same type of thing that we did for sis
uh and the statement is a little bit
harder to
sort of say and parse but essentially
what it says is that
if you can solve that we you can solve
sort of gap
shortest vector gap shortest independent
vectors
problem with related parameters okay so
i'm not going to
so there's a quantum version of this
reduction there's a classical version
so it's it gets a little bit uh
um more technical so this is all i'm
gonna sort of say about it
okay the same kind of worst case to
average case you can also do for lwe
essentially
happy to tell you more offline if you
want
okay so let's do crypto okay so
this you know the problem the hardness
of lwe already gives you
immediately a one-way function and in
fact even a pseudorandom
generator right click right and what is
this function
this is this is the function right by
definition
this is a one-way function and uh by
definition of a decisional
we this is pseudorandom so one has to be
a little bit careful to ensure that this
actually expands
otherwise uh it isn't very meaningful to
say pseudohunter but uh
but it does if you set the arrow to be
small enough
the entropy in the input is larger than
the smaller than the entropy in the
output
so that since it expands okay so one way
function very easy
so random generator very easy from
decisional attribute
okay now let's do
a little bit more let's do encryption
okay so how does encryption work
the secret key is an lwe secret yes
right and uh in fact let's actually
start with the secret key encryption
and i'll show you how to make it into a
public key in a minute
okay so uh the secret key is a random
vector is a random lwe secret
how do i encrypt i pick a random vector
a
also in zq to the n i compute the inner
product
add the lwe noise to it so you know
whatever noise distribution lw
is hard for pick at random from it add
it
and add the message use this as a
one-time pad
to absorb with the message i'm doing
something a little bit funky here i'm
not adding the message i'm adding
the message times q over two
but really think about it as an error
correcting code of the message
right so if i if my message was zero or
one
which is what i just what i have and i
add a little bit of error to it
you don't know you can't tell whether it
was a zero or a one
if i encoded it this way and you added a
little bit of error
anything smaller than q over four or
something like that
you can decode right so really what's
happening here is
i am going to use the lwe sample which
is this
as a one-time pad to mask the message
not the message but the error correcting
code of the message
okay very straightforward just kind of
comes out of the definition of filter
beauty
so why is this secure semantic security
follows straightforwardly from the
decisional from the hardness of
decisional lwe
why because decision we say that this
guy is
random so then it's a one-time pad what
are you going to do
right that's that
and how do you decrypt also
straightforward once i i get the
ciphertext and i have the secret key
which is the s which is the lwe secret
once i have the secret i can compute a
in a product s
subtract it from here and what i get is
a message more or less
except it's error correct encoder the
message plus some noise i can decode it
and that's what it is
i get something like m times q over 2
plus an error
and i can tell whether m was 0 or 1 if
it was zero
it's zero plus a small error if it's one
it's q over two plus a small error i can
distinguish
that right so we get correctness as long
as the error is
not too large
so this error is is a mixed bag right i
mean
you need the guy for security because
otherwise uh
it's learning without errors which isn't
particularly
hard but on the other hand uh
you know this error as you will see in
chai stock is going to cause a lot of
problems
when you do homomorphic operations you
you'll end up in big trouble
this is secret key interpretation how do
you make this public key
okay there are two ways to do it in fact
they amount to essentially the same
thing
there's a devious way and there's a
straightforward way okay so let me do
the devious way first okay the dps way
says this scheme is additively
homomorphic
because if i add an encryption if i have
an encryption of m
and an encryption of m prime if i add
them together i get an encryption of m
plus m prime
mod 2. maybe with a little bit more
error but
you know between friends you know what
is an error okay so
that i think i can add a bounded number
of these uh these guys
that's that's easy and now
let me invoke a beautiful theorem of uh
of
rothblum again let me not tell you which
rod bloom it is i'll leave it to you to
figure it out that's my error right
that's my uncertainty
so beautiful beautiful theorem which
says that
any secret key encryption can be
converted into a public encryption well
wait a minute any secret key homomorphic
additively homomorphic encryption can be
converted
into a public encryption well here is a
secret key additively homomorphic
encryption
done okay let's go home
it's a beautiful beautiful theorem and
in fact you would think it
is complicated but it's not even i mean
it actually preserves the efficiency
more or less it's very nice theorem okay
that's one way to get public
interruption
that's not a particularly sort of
explicit way to do it so let me
tell you exactly explicitly
how to do it and in fact what i'm gonna
do is an instantiation of lot bloom's
theorem
in fact rod bloom's theorem is a
generalization of what i'm going to do
okay that's the heart
that's the way things came about
so so what is it right so
i have a secret key the same as before
no change now i have to come up with a
public key
what is a public key a public key is
essentially a bunch of lwe samples
relative to the secret keys namely
random matrix a
together with s transpose a plus an
error
so now you look at it one way to look at
it
is that each column of this matrix a
together with the corresponding sort of
column of b
is an encryption of 0 from before right
it's it's a vector a
together with s in a product a plus
noise
plus 0. so the public key is a bunch of
encryptions of 0.
that's what it is right
how do i encrypt i take the public key
and multiply it with
a with a random 0 1 vector r so r
i didn't say it explicitly here but r is
a random zero one vector
short vector more generally so what am i
doing here i'm really taking
a bunch of these encryptions of zero and
i'm taking a random linear combination
of these guys
and also i have to do the same thing to
b right to me b transpose r plus the
message
that's really what's happening right
once of encryption is zero i take a
random linear combination
uh and uh and that's it that's the
ciphertext this is a public key
encryption
algorithm how do i decrypt i just look
at b
transpose r and that's really what is b
b is s transpose a plus the error times
r
is more or less s transpose a times r
forget the error
right and s transpose
a times r is something i can compute i
have a times r i have the secret key
when i'm decrypting
i can compute this subtract it from
from this quantity i get the message
plus the error or i recover the message
okay so really the so what is the
general principle here
to convert a secret key interruption
into a public encryption
the public key is a bunch of encryptions
of zero this is more or less what
ron's theorem says i gave it away
but more or less right so a public key
which is a bunch of encryptions of zero
how do you encrypt you pick a random
linear combination of these encryptions
of zero
and add the message to it right now of
course
by for more visits and this is an
encryption of the message and
you can decrypt it that secretly right
this is a
beautiful beautiful theorem i love this
good
why is uh why do you get security right
security follows from a decisional lwe
uh but that's not quite good enough you
you need to argue a little bit more
right so this is nwe
for example says that the public key if
i look at it
what does that look like right it's a
bunch of lwe samples
decision lwe says that looks random that
really looks like random junk
now what am i doing here right
i am effectively taking something that
looks like a random junk
and uh multiplying it
with a random zero one vector so the
ciphertext
is a
very straight plus
0 and mq over 2.
right so this is what the public key
looks like b is random now so this whole
matrix a and b together is totally
random
and what am i doing i'm taking a random
matrix which is public by the way it's a
random public matrix
and multiplying it with the random
secret 0 1 vector
now you apply left to rush lambda
implied so
11 right
and and you get uniformity so
this guy looks statistically looks
random
right that's what uh an instantiation of
the leftovers lemma says you pick a
random matrix
you have a vector r that comes from a
distribution with entropy not
necessarily random not random in fact
you do a times r that gives you a
uniform derivative
right as long as things kind of match up
as long as there's enough entropy
that i can play with right
and that's it that gives you securely
this is a public encryption scheme and
this is ruggef's
original public encryption system yes
sorry just to be clear is
is r like a uh encryption
indeed indeed it is it is the randomness
that i uh
every time i generate a fresh r yes yes
any uh any other questions can answer
okay good so this is public encryption
okay so that's that so we did collision
resistance we did public encryption i'm
getting happier and happier
we'll see how far i get okay so there
was a question some
you know uh in the last talk that uh you
know i i
talked about sis which is an average
case heart problem average case problem
lwe which is another average case
problem what do these things have to do
with lattices
right other than the fact that there is
a worst case average case reduction
right why are these slightest problems
okay well good question so let me look
at the sis function remember it was this
function that mapped
zero one vectors to a times r mod q
and this guy is lwe function
and you know um like i said this is a
subjective function
compresses many solutions and this is an
injective function for the appropriate
parameters
okay so what does it have to do with
lattice okay
so given a matrix a i can define
there are two ways to define a lattice
at least two ways to define
a lotus defined lattice corresponding to
a
one is to say let me look at the
kernel of this matrix mod q
right this is a a lattice
it's a it's a linear it's a discrete
space it's a linear space
and uh it's about us right the set of
vectors
t integer vectors t i mean now i'm not
going to
talk about mod anything right so the set
of integer vectors t
such that a times t when i look at it
mod q
rather another way to say this is that a
times t is a multiple of consistent
multiples of q
right i look at the set of vectors take
any two such vectors
add them it is also a vector of this
form 0 is in the set
it's relatively closed and it's discrete
clearly because these are integer
vectors
any such object is a lattice okay so i
didn't tell you this with
that's what it is so this is one way to
define a lattice right this is a kernel
lattice or the or the
purple lattice i'm going to call it
another way to define a lattice is to
say i'm going to take all linear
combinations
of the rows of a so these are m
dimensions so whether this is an m
dimensional lattice right because i have
a
which is n by m and t which is an
m-dimensional vector
which is m-dimensional that is this is
also an m-dimensional lattice which is
take all linear combinations of the rows
of a and this is the
image of the linear map a as opposed to
the kernel on the left
and uh you know uh to make this into a
lattice i i
add essentially q z to the m to this guy
right so so one way to think about it
is that uh a
is uh
a1 up to a n this is kind of the other
way to
write it um a so
so what do i do i write a 1 here a 2
here
and so on and so forth i populate this
this is an n dimensional space
and i add q times
all the unit vectors to it
i'm going to also do q1 a1 plus 2 times
a2 which goes here and comes back here
so on and so forth
and so on and so forth right so
essentially i take the linear space
of a i add all vectors that are
multiples of q to it
yeah yeah it's the same thing yeah just
because i uh i
added q z to the m to it right good
point
all right so these are two lattices
right this is also a lattice because
again
zero is in the lattice uh it's discrete
uh
you know it's additively closed right
solaris
so what is sis sis is exactly the
problem of finding short vectors
in this lattice right so 8 well
forget about this for a moment sis is
exactly exactly finding short vectors in
the kernel of the lattice
and what is lwe lwe is a problem of well
i give you a vector in this lattice plus
a little bit of error
decode it back to the original lattice
point it's a bounded distance decoding
bounded because i add a little bit of
error
right no more than enough to
sort of make this make the solution
unique
right so this is this is why so both sis
and lwe are the lattice problems one is
the short vector problem i'm not
asking for the shortest vector just give
me one vector that is whose norm is
bounded by something
right and this is the bounded distance
decoding problem
right
okay so it's it's a you know it's a it's
important to sort of keep this in mind
uh and we'll get to it uh
um in a few in a few minutes
so you still make a general result which
says that
if you have i mean obviously
a lot of these hardness problems are
there
so like i think that's what uh your
guinea was saying that when you bring in
this
more cute thing yeah is there like a
general intuition was this q
size has to be or how is it relating to
the
good point um uh so q
really uh so what so a concrete way to
ask this question is how do you pick q
right i mean what's uh um is q equals
two good enough
right uh what is the right choice of q
one way to answer this question is say
you know let's run the worst case
traverse case reduction
right and whatever q comes out of it is
the right q right so
the worst case status case reduction
typically says that q has to be larger
than something
right typically polynomial in n
iotic reduction for isis reduction you
need q to be larger than n which is the
dimension of the lattice
and again for if you're on the worst
case studies reduction for lwe you get
something similar
so pick any queue that is larger than a
minimum bound and that's good enough as
opposed to
a in discrete log saying that you have
to pick q to be random
right you can make an assumption that
discrete log is hard for every group
of a certain size but you have to
explicitly make that assumption too
very quickly because things change on
this error distribution we usually swipe
it down
and it just right now in the motor
technology do we care if it's uniform
gaussian now it's like all equivalent by
now
good question um so there is a
uh there is a work of daniel a that
shows the hardness of lwe for
uniform errors from certain range but
it's not
completely uh black box i mean there are
all sorts of bells and whistles
attached to it so you can show something
for uniformly random errors
but i don't think there's a unified
framework that says
it doesn't come up in the reduction
we will swipe it under the rug and it
won't come up in
any of the crypto in other words you can
start from lwe with any error
distribution you can work with it as
long as it is bounded
and the hardness will reduce to lwe with
that error distribution now the question
is how hard is that
right and we run through the worst case
stop risk case reduction
some applications you use like gaussian
plus gaussian is another gaussian so i'm
just trying to see if it's crucial
we won't actually we will be agnostic of
the
particular distribution of the errors
we'll just use boundaries
in fact if you look at public key
encryption that's sort of all
right to use the fact that the sum of a
bunch of error terms is small
so it's true if the order terms
themselves are small
this is a great question by the way i
mean uh you know okay
so characterize the distributions of uh
errors for which uh lwe start or rather
show reductions between different error
distributions
i don't think the situation is uh is
resolved at all
so shall we move on
15 minutes which is not nearly enough
um okay let's let's see what we can do
okay so so that's sis that's lwe
we went as far as public interruption
let's move a little bit
further so let's sort of
go to our third technique which is
trapdoors for lattices
again our starting point is that uh you
know lattices have many bases
good bases bad bases right i mean good
short and
bad is long what's the point i mean i
can
you know i can you know i can call a dog
a cat but i mean that doesn't make it a
cat right i mean
what's the point of labeling these
things good and bad
right ideally you want that a good basis
lets me do things that a bad basis
doesn't
that's the content of the of this good
and bad business
what is it that a good basis lets me do
that a bad basis doesn't
turns out this is what it lets me do let
me solve the close
vector problems not the closest vector
what it says is given a basis b
and a y and a point y in the space in rm
there's a dimension of the lattice find
me a vector v in the lattice which is
close enough to uh to y
and again the small is a parameter of
the problem
right so not necessarily asking you to
find the closest vector i'm just going
to find a vector that is close enough to
uh
to the point i am going to claim
that if you have a short basis
you can solve this problem better
than if you have a long nasty basis
so so let's see how to do this okay so
this is again
a very uh famous uh
nice algorithm of bubba so this is
called the bubba
rounding algorithm how does it work
it works like you expect it to work in a
sense right
so you have a basis this is my bad basis
right
i draw the parallelogram for the bad
bases in fact there are many such
parallelograms right and if i take this
i kind of shift it here that's another
parallelogram so on and so forth and
these things style the lattice
right first thing i do i figure out
the parallelogram where y lies this is
actually pretty easy to do
right so write y as a linear combination
of the basis vectors
not with integer coefficients because
it's not in the lattice
and take the coefficients round them
down and that gives me the
bottom left corner of the pipeline
that's easy to figure out and now what
do i do i have a parallel pipette i know
that the guy lives inside the
parliamentar pipeline
what do you think i should do
just make sure that we have enough
espresso uh espresso filled bodies
ready to prove theorems what would you
do
just round i mean what else are you
gonna do
right just round what does that mean
you uh you figure out which corner
of this parallelogram is closest to this
lattice point
you can do that you essentially write y
as the basis times
a vector and you round that vector
around the coefficient vector up or down
depending on
right round it to the nearest
corner of the parallelogram and that's
it you say that is the close vector
done okay that's the algorithm
now the question is how well does this
algorithm do
okay so just uh my pictures are terrible
but let me
try to approximate something here this
guy right
if i look at the parallelogram the
closest point is this green
guy so i'm going to output the green guy
as my close vector
why because i'm only looking at the
points at the corners of the parallel
pipeline the rest of it is immaterial to
me right that's what the rounding
algorithm does
in other words the rounding algorithm
doesn't see the fact that there is
a point outside the parallelogram that's
even closer to me than one of the
corners
that basis let me look at another basis
this isn't this is another basis right
look at the parallelogram let me around
it and this is what uh what i get
and in fact this is a closer vector than
this guy i mean
that's the way i picked my picture but
that is in general the case
right that's what i get okay so
where does where do things stop how
close is this vector as a function of
the
quality of the basis
right so here's something you can show
in fact it's easy
to show it's a approximately 15 second
exercise
right the distance between the point
that the
grounding algorithm outputs which is v
and the point you cared about y is at
most
the sum of the lengths of the basis
vectors which basis vectors the basis
vectors that you used
to round not quite that half of that but
yeah
half okay right some of these things why
because you know
where did i go i mean i rounded to one
of the corners of this parallel pipe
the distance is at most the sum of the
lengths of the basis vectors
times a half because i only moved a half
right so that's it what do you see
from this you see that the quality of
the solution here
how close is the lattice point to your
target point y
depends on how good the basis is how
large the basis vectors are
right in a very explicit way
you can uh improve this a little bit by
what's called the nearest plane
algorithm also due to bubbae
and you can show something like this if
you don't know what this
is uh don't worry about it these are the
gram-schmidt
vectors lengths of the gram-schmidt
vectors of the basis
basis okay this is slightly better than
what's above but
essentially again that says here's a
measure of the quality of the basis
if it's better in this measure you get
closer vectors
okay so that's so what is the what is
the model of the story
the model says better bases with shorter
vectors
give you closer vectors it lets you
solve
close vector problem better so that's
why
a good basis is a good basis not just
because i called it good
right no but it doesn't say that the
best basis is not good right because it
could be
it gives just one direction
okay all right uh the bad basis is uh
this is a tight uh
uh connection right so if you look at
the bad basis if you look at any bases
in fact
you can find a point where the distance
between uh that and the
so the close vector that the algorithm
outputs is something like the sum of the
lengths of the basis vectors is not
quite right because uh yeah
good question i want to say yes
but uh it's a fraction of it's a
fraction of points that
live very far from inside the parallel
pipette that live very far from any
lattice point so as the dimension grows
again it depends on what the lattice is
but i
think that's it should be true
yeah no no no not at all i mean in fact
one cannot hope to say something like
that right uh and that is sort of the uh
yeah yeah it's just that um you know uh
there are two things here right so one i
give you i'm gonna give you a bad basis
right and a conjecture i assume
that uh with that it's hard to solve the
close vector problem
and two i will keep the good basis for
myself and i know that
i'm going to solve it better than you
under the assumption right
that's all i want to do indeed indeed
indeed
yes yes so that's the assumption right
so really the content of this is that uh
is is that good basis do very well
right
so so here is something that lets me do
better and
not so much you right and that's a trap
door
trapdoor is a good basis and this again
this was an idea that you can trace all
the way back
to uh the first public encryption of
fighting work and we'll get back to this
point
in the next 10 minutes but this was
explicitly so this is explicitly an idea
due to uh goldrich kolbaster and helleve
okay again so what is an idea for if i
want to build a trapdoor function
i generate somehow a random lattice plus
a good basis so i come up with them
together
and the function is really uh you know
something that takes a lattice point as
input and noises input and adds
outputs a noisy lattice point right
this is again very rough we're going to
make it concrete and precise in a slide
the idea again is that if you just have
the bad basis if you have just a
description of the lattice
it's hard to invert it's hard to find a
close enough vector
but if you had a good basis you will go
back right it's roughly the idea and
that's in fact the
trapdoor function construction of a shy
or dead and sharpie
okay so the question is what does it
mean what does that mean a random
lattice uh
what does it mean a good basis for the
sliders right so that's i mean
we were struggling with this notion of
picking a random point from allah so
you have to you have to do something
here
so so what is a random ladder for us we
already saw
two different kinds of lattices that you
can generate that you can define based
on a
matrix a in n by m matrix right
the lattice and the sis lattice and the
lwe lattice right the
kernel and the image and that is
what it's going to be a random lattice
is just going to be a random matrix in
uh z q to the n by m right and that
defines
two types of lattices the lambda of a
and lambda purple phi
that's what i mean by a random lattice
okay and i want a trapdoor and trapdoor
is what it's a short basis
of some letters and which lattice is it
i'm going to pick lambda purpose
okay because reasons i mean because it
has
it has short vectors so i have to pick
something that has short vectors and
that is lambda purple of a
why because remember we said many uh
variables small number of equations
there are many solutions
likely there is a small one and this is
what it is
okay so what is this what does it mean a
short basis of lambda purpose a
this is a full rank matrix t so the
columns of these matrix
this matrix are the vectors in the
lattice such that a
times t equals 0 mod q what does that
mean so look at the each column of
t a times a column of t is zero marquee
which means that this column lives in
the kernel of a
it's a short vector in the kernel of a
each column of t should have small norm
right so the trapdoor is a collection of
vectors
each vector lives in the kernel of a and
each vector is short and these set of
vectors has full rank
that is my notion of a trapdoor and that
is in fact
a short basis for this guy
the purple
okay
good a little bit this guy doing what's
the guy doing here
okay well look i mean if you if you
think about it you realize that there is
something funky going on here
right
a times t i claim t is what t is a full
rank matrix is an m by m matrix a square
matrix
i want a times t to be 0 mod q
right so for rank matrix a times t zero
mod q
so what could the rank of t be mod q
and there are several vectors each row
of a
which killed this matrix vector times
this matrix is zero so there are several
vectors in the kernel of t
so it cannot have full rank right so
what am i i mean it seems like there's
something
uh there's a contradiction going on here
right so i want a full rank matrix
but i also want the data times t zero
marquee what's that gonna
good excellent so the question is full
rank over what
clearly this matrix cannot be full rank
over mod q
because of these two conditions but it
could be full rank over the integers
right so something is full rank uh
mod q means that it's full rank over the
integers not the other way around
right in fact that is that is what uh
okay so this is very very important this
is where you
okay one you can get one doesn't make
any sense
okay so this is our trapdoor a bunch of
vectors
from the kernel of a short vectors and
they together form
a full rank over the integers set
okay so not sure what
to do exactly but let me show you uh
what good is this trapdoor at the very
least i want to
show you this and we'll see what uh
where to go from there
okay okay so i claim
that with this notion of trapdoor if i
can somehow generate a random a
together with the trapdoor i can make
both the functions that i defined before
namely the sis function
and the lwe function into trapdoor
functions
they're not just one way function and so
random generators we all the
you know all of a sudden we jumped into
kryptomania
but we get troubler functions why is
that the case so this is our lwe
function
right i claim that given the door for a
the notion that i defined just now i can
invert this function
okay how do i do that
well i just you know have a matrix i
have a vector what am i going to do i
multiply them right
i have the output this function i have t
multiply them what do i get this guy
goes to zero
right that the trout door is designed to
kill this uh
this a and what i'm left with is e
times t mod q right that's what i get
so now what would i like right i would
like to take this e times t
mod q and multiply it with t inverse mod
q
right and i get e and once i get e
subtract it from s transpose a plus e do
gaussian elimination you're done
right so far
it seems like everything works but i
didn't use the shortness
of tea right why is it a short basis so
far what all all i said could work
you know regardless of what this uh
basis was
you cannot because t doesn't have an
inverse mod q
so you cannot find e maybe you can find
some linear equations in e some subspace
where e falls but that's not good enough
that's where this comes in right
a times t mod q is e times t because
these guys are all small
so mod q doesn't do me anything
and now i can invert i can multiply this
with the inverse of t
over the integers over over rationals
and recovery and that's it
so this is exactly why i mean the
difference between uh
mod q full rank mod q and full rank over
the integers
really it's very absolutely crucial here
okay so that's that
okay so that gives me an injective
trapdoor function
i can also make the sis function which
is remember it's compressing into a
trapdoor function as well
so how do i do that
well you know what's my goal my goal is
i'm given a times y
a times r which is b and r is small
right my goal is to find this out
what do i do i start with b
i can compute some y such that a times y
equals b
i mean you know i can't sort of jump
around and vacuum right i have to start
somewhere
here's where i start a times y equals b
y
is not necessarily short so this is
something you can find with gaussian
elimination
right i mean nothing really funky going
on here
and now i do the following
i find let me put up one more thing
i find i look at y this is a vector in z
to the m
i look at the lattice the kernel lattice
generated by a
and i look at i find a vector v in the
kernel lattice
that's close to y i use remember baba's
rounding algorithm to do this so what
does that mean
and now i say well you know i take this
y i take the v
the close vector that bubba gave me
subtract them
i claim that is a solution that's a
short vector that's a short r
such that a times r is b mod cube
right so why is that the case first of
all this is short because thank you
bye-bye right
this is a close vector so y minus v is
short and
and i claim this is a solution to uh to
a times something equals p
why because a times r is the same as um
a times a y because a times v is zero
v is in the kernel of a 0
you get b mod q right that's it so
really
you know the problem of inverting
the sis function is exactly the problem
of
solving the close vector problem
so the same notion of trapdoor
makes both the functions the injector
the size function and the
lwe function into trapdoor functions
but they're different kinds of trader
functions right one is injective one is
subjective and and in a sense they're
duals of each other
right so and this is actually one can
make this precise
uh you know the lattices uh the kernel
lattice and the
image largest they're more or less duals
of each other
does it require any new assumptions so
the same assumptions this
information theoretically follows at the
gap
what do you mean the hardness of this uh
assumption yes you can generate the
short
you know the thing good good good so
so the thing i haven't told you is how
do i
generate a lot of a together with the
trapdoor
right and it had better be the case that
the a i generate
in this way is random because otherwise
i cannot
i mean otherwise why is it hard why is
this function hard right
so i have to generate a random a which
gives me hardness because of sis
together with a short basis that's what
i have to do
but in particular well i mean this is
algorithmic thing but you need to show
the existence of uh
you know this kind of gap such that you
know this traveler actually works
so that kind of follows from the
information i mean the existence theorem
is that a short uh phrase i mean you can
make an assumption
that generate something is random yeah
but the fact that short things kind of
exist is just by counting or
the fact that uh short vectors and short
solutions exist is
either by counting or by minkowski's
essentially counting right minkowski is
counting
so you get two at the price of one you
get two trapdoor
functions okay so
all right so uh
let's see how to go from here
let's discuss it i'm open to discussion
okay how much
hey how much do you pay
exactly um so
so i want to show at least uh one thing
right uh which is
not so much to i want to show one thing
which is uh
how much does five minutes cost
okay you know what let me actually get
to it without talking right
um okay so so what i want to show is
is how to generate a random lattice
together with one vector
in the kernel one short vector in the
curve now if you have one you get two
you get three
uh we get everything okay so uh it's not
quite uh
true i mean this is where the so the
heart of the difficulty lies but i won't
get to it
again if you want to do crypto all you
have to know is that there exists a way
to sample this
with this
okay so so let's do the warm-up
and that'll be it right so this is
essentially a
technique that goes all the way back to
itai's work and
it's also also concept in the work of
item work
and this is a way to generate a random a
with one short vector
how would you do it right i cannot start
from a random a
and uh hope to find a short vector
that's actually hard
so i have to do both at the same time
how do i do it i pick an a prime which
is the same as the a
except it is missing one column at the
very end right it's m
minus one columns
so this is part of my a part of my
instance
and i pick r which is a random zero one
again of length m minus 1 this is my
solution so
i constructed part of my instance and i
constructed a solution
and now i'm going to complete it right
so i'm going to
define my lattice a that's my instance
to be a prime with another column which
is
a prime times r essentially more or less
at minus a prime times r
and what is the vector that i get out of
it what is the trapdoor vector i
by doing this i got for free a vector in
the kernel of this lattice which is r
and one if you multiply the two you get
zero mod q
that's beautiful technique very simple
but
really nice okay so i have to show many
things i have to show that a
that i constructed this way is close to
random and that's by leftover
lemma this was random to begin with and
this was essentially a random matrix
times a zero one vector or random zero
one vector
and as long as this guy has enough
entropy you get uniformity that you
do by fixing parameters right as long as
you have this guarantee you're done
a times r is 0 mod q rather actually
sorry so a times t
is 0 mod q sorry
and t has small norm because each entry
of r is either 0 or 1 so how large can
it be
square root of m done
that's it now if i can do one why can't
i do two
right i pick uh not not sort of
one column less matrix that's one column
less but two columns less
and i pick one vector that gives me uh
one thing that gives me you know one
drop director i give another thing that
gives me another trap director
unfortunately you know
life is not that not that easy because
every time i pick a new trapdoor vector
i'm adding one column to the to the
matrix
so i say one i get one i said two i get
two three i get three
i'm never going to get as many trapdoor
vectors
as the number of columns of a never
going to happen
we're never going to get a trapdoor for
full basis
we saw that unless you have a full basis
i'm in trouble i
what is what does inverse mean how do i
invert these
these functions right
so this is this is something that you
have to solve this is a this is really
the
the the major sort of idea in a work of
i tai from 99
considerably simplified over the years
and uh the so the state of the art is a
work of machancho and picot
which are it's two slides but i uh
unless i pay tal hadoos
i don't get two slides right so uh
so so really you know i'm somewhat happy
because i told you uh uh what these
things are
not so much how i get the trapdoors but
you don't have to know right i mean what
you don't know
won't uh won't hurt you
so on and so forth it's
it's all very very nice and uh simple
um clearly
okay so at least i have to tell you one
open question right i mean
what is the talk without an open
question so
here's the thing i showed you
two kinds of trouble functions okay one
is an injective function
but it's actually an expanding function
right it's the lwe function
and i showed you a compressing function
which is a many to one by definition of
many to one function it's actually a
subjective function as well
right it's a bit like you know what do
you say in english you know
have your cake and eat it right i mean
can you get one function that is both
injective and subjective in other words
can you get a
trapdoor permutation no lattice
right and uh if you get a trapdoor
permutation you get all sorts of
nice things and i'm not asking this
question there are certain questions you
can ask for the sake of asking it right
and i claim this is not such a question
there's something very deep
going on here which is you know
where does the hardness of these lattice
problems come from
they come from the fact that you have
these noise terms right i mean you have
something that is
not exact you you you destroy
structure to get hardness the question
of trapped or permutations really asks
can you get
perfect structure
from some assumption that is inherently
noisy
permutations yes indeed so forget
trapdoor
one way is already one paper mutations
is already
you don't know all right so this i think
uh
you know and an izkay proofs which will
follow from trader permutations this is
something that has haunted me for
i don't know like seven years eight
years since i started working on
led assistant someone puts me out of my
misery you know i'll be uh
i'll be more than i'll be very happy in
fact you know i was tempted to kind of
put money down
on the stage you know in front of the
camera but i'll resist
100 bucks for the guy who uh not
eventually i mean
with a bounded time two years okay so
two years gave me a traveler permutation
in fact forget it just give me an
idk proof for all of np
right you can take a look
okay so so this hey so you know what
just to avoid uh you know
giving you a hundred bucks of my uh run
cash let me make it harder okay so let
me
i want trouble permutations from a worst
case hardness assumption on lattices
that's uh not a very high bar right
and that's uh that's what i want and
that you know you
you can you can pick ideal lattices if
you want you can work with ideal
lattices but it has to be
something with the worst case traverse
case reduction even better
if you construct something from lwe you
know
best of all very very happy
okay so uh so i think uh
i it's way too much
this is it this is thank you
i did all these things